um but no i am so excited to do this to
talk about cannabis to talk about viola
here with al harrington and ai so i
already know everything about the great
story with your grandma and how she
really got you like into it wanting to
do this business i know your amazing
story about smoking with vicki so i want
to get into more of the nitty-gritty
stuff starting with why we are calling
it cannabis because i automatically like
want to say weed that's what i call it
but i know it's really important that
we're kind of de-stigmatizing that and
calling it cannabis can you talk about
why that is yeah i mean that's just you
know
that's just part of like you know
the industry evolving
right being able to talk about it about
what it really is because we all thought
it was reefer yeah that's what i thought
i got the guys
growing up right you know and this
younger generation is all about gas yeah
but you know at the end of the day we
are
now you know
transitioning a lot of these
conversations and i feel like as we go
into these different rooms and you know
talking to church leaders and
politicians and different things like
that we have to call it cannabis yeah
just kind of evolve it from there
i know for you you have probably learned
so much throughout this process of like
really getting into the business of
cannabis what's the number one thing
you've learned so far
um the positive things
oh you're mike oh i'm sorry i see how i
rely on this yeah
the positive things um that al
experience explain to me
that it does and and um just killing the
bad stigma
um
it was always you know coming up it was
a bad thing
you know i mean um and just hearing all
the positive things when al is educating
me um
on the cannabis
and um
you know i'm a rookie right now at it
you know what i mean but you know a
couple years from now you know i
probably know more than him yeah i love
that now you know we got some some
premium flour right here and i said to
my producer i was like you are quite
literally getting your flowers you know
because you now have your own strain
tell me about this strain ai
so i'll tell you i'll tell you more
about it he he know that um
i can i can do it to get away
[Laughter]
so this uh this process uh started
probably about a year and a half ago to
be honest you know to be able to create
a strain from scratch it takes about a
year
uh we have really good partners uh with
these cultivators in genesis called
green dragon
uh my vp of strategy uh stephanie oracle
is the one that helped me you know
curate this strain so one of the things
that alan told us in the beginning was
that i was just asking like what does he
like was his flavor profiles different
things like that and the first thing he
said was like well you know i like
champagne he's like make something that
tastes like don p
and when we heard that i'm thinking okay
um i mean we got to have some type of
grape right when we think about our
culture and in cannabis like a lot of
the exotic weed and different things
like that it looks it looks purple
different things like that so we came up
with grape stomper across there with
secret cushman's
and when i also thought about this is a
culture play for us right because he
represents culture so we've been very
specific in regards of who we're really
going after with this with this genetics
right and it's our people people that
look like us and our people like gas
they like really strong weed so we were
able to do this this cross of grape
stock grape stomping secret cushman's
and it tests anywhere between 32 to 36
total thc
and you know it will definitely sit you
down
and when you think about the grape and
the mint flavoring you know it tastes
like a little bit like champagne so
we've had a lot of people without you
know that's like the first time i'm
actually saying that was our intent but
there's been a lot of people that have
reached out to me and said yo this
tastes actually tastes like a glass of
champagne when you first hit it yeah
yeah right so that was that was our
motivation behind it and with it being
you know his first string and we're
calling it 96 and we think about
what he represented when he came in in
96 it was he was a game changer changed
the game forever you know on the court
and off the court and not only for
himself but even for every athlete that
played in the league because at that
point is when
guys started realizing that this
corporate life that they wanted us to
live that we didn't have to live there
we could actually be ourselves and still
be the star of the show yeah so i think
all of those things when he did it
and i i was just saying i wanted to
taste like don b
and um and had to be strong gas
but was that accomplished i think so
yeah it was actually accomplished okay
so i want to talk about the role of weed
in the mba you know i thought it was
really great how last year during kind
of the coveted season they suspended
random testing for cannabis
do you think there will be a day in the
league where that is completely done no
more random testing it is a substance
everyone can use do you see that day
coming potentially i think it's now it's
already happening yeah i mean this is
obviously year three now because you had
the you had the uh what is it the bubble
you had all of last season and then you
have this season starting and you know i
think the nba is pretty smart they're
not addressing it right they're not
saying we're taking it off the man list
mm-hmm they're just saying we suspended
it yeah right and kind of you might just
receive it forever but i wanna i just i
would like to just take this time just
to say that you know i really uh give
the players a lot of credit that none of
them have abused this opportunity which
i didn't think they would do anyway
because i always say like you know we
all have access to liquor
right
and when i know i got to come compete
against ai i'm not getting drunk before
i'm about to play and i'm not going to
get high before i got to guard a.i right
and i just think that all the guys are
very professional and we understand that
and i think that these guys have done a
really really good job at that in being
able to keep it separate right because
they're definitely using i know for a
fact oh for sure you know we get calls
here and there action for product and
you know it's just a beautiful thing and
i just think that you know for athletes
it was something that needed to happen
we needed an alternative way to deal
with a lot of the issues that we deal
with
and in the past it's only been liquor
right or it's been you know
pharmaceutical drugs and you know the
vicodins and different things like that
because you know we deal with a lot of
things and most people forget that we
are human beings and i think that's
coming out a lot man with the mental
health and mental health issues that are
you know being raised all the time
because we seem like superman and we got
so much money like why what kind of
problems do they have but no we have the
same problems you have yeah we just
actually have money
yeah
it doesn't make things easier so just
you know guys great job and i'm so happy
that the league has taken his stance and
you know hopefully one day you know
viola will be on one of these jerseys
can you talk about a time in your career
where you would have benefited from
there not being the stigma around me but
about it being okay do you not have
cannabis while you're a basketball
player
yeah i probably didn't have to go on the
program then
that was it um and and i could be free
with it like i wanted to be
back then you know like i said it was
this stigma that it was so bad
back then you know what i mean and i you
know i went through going uh through the
bad boy thing when i first came into the
league and the fact that i had all these
guys with me and we smoked you know
marijuana and this that the third and it
was like
he was labeled as a villain
you know what i mean or a bad guy
for smoking and um that's what i
remember
the most you know what i mean that i had
to go through
you know with that i hear that people in
the crowd you know calling me weed head
and on the road yeah and stuff like that
so
you know it was bad you know because i
because i had um when i first got nearly
i think when i was a rookie um
i had got um stopped and i had some
some weed on me and i actually went to
jail for it you know what i mean and now
you know
all these years later
look what we had and look how far we've
come yeah absolutely and you know even
just going off that i know you were a
part of the group of of people who
wanted to write a letter to biden to
have him party you know non-violent
offenders who you know were associated
with cannabis and there's very obvious
racial disparities when it comes to you
know being arrested being put into the
system for marijuana i think black
people are four times more likely to go
to jail for having um cannabis than a
white person so can you just talk about
kind of how you've seen that shift and
how in some ways it is kind of
frustrating how other groups of people
are profiting off this thing that we so
often have been victimized for using
yeah i would like to just start with
just new york you know since new york
has decriminalized and made it legal
uh arrest in the black community is down
95
insane
95
and then when you think about cannabis
arrests in other places where black
people only represent you know 20 30 of
the population
and we're still the ones that invested
you know 85 percent more than you like
to your point so it's definitely a huge
issue and that's something that
obviously with this partnership
and everything that viola stands for
being that we are a cannabis company
with purpose is all about
changing the stigma first um you know
creating more opportunities for people
of color in the cannabis space because
to your point there's now billions of
dollars being made
and the people that are making it don't
look like us
you know cannabis was used to destroy
our community and now you know they're
still keeping us out of it right through
all these different regulations and
different things like that so we need to
change that because this is generational
wealth at risk you know there's been so
many opportunities other things
industries that black people have
pioneered you know rice sugar cotton uh
alcohol the lottery yeah we created the
lottery we have no ownership in that so
we feel like there's a huge we have a
huge issue with that and i honestly feel
like if we don't do the work it won't
get done because i think there's a lot
of window dressing with people saying
they care about social equity and they
care about black people getting
opportunity and just saying it they're
just saying it right because and it's
just checking a box yes right so we're
we're here to kind of put hold people
accountable for that and you know we're
trying to do it through our work the
work that we're doing on a daily basis
yeah absolutely well you guys are
definitely pioneers in this space shout
out to y'all this is this is super super
exciting speaking of pioneer you know we
have a huge pioneer in basketball i've
been so excited to do this interview um
and yesterday i actually called james
harden because i was really excited i
know that how much he respects you loves
your game looks up to you i asked him if
he had some questions that he wanted me
to ask you and he wheels returning he's
like there's so many ways i could go
like ai has meant so much to me in my
life so i want to ask you some of the
questions that james had for you all
right okay okay so his first one which
is something i wanted to delve into as
well he said
can you ask ai
how often he thinks about not having a
title
um
never think about it
really never
and
until i
hear something like that question yeah
you're like
you can cast your vote i came close
tried but you know it didn't happen but
let me tell you why i don't
because look what god has done for me
you know what i mean i come from the mud
and ended up being
the first pick
in the draft
of out of
all these people in the world i'm the
number one pick in the world rookie of
the year
um
mvp of our league
um
all nba
um
all-star game mvp
olympian you know what i mean like i've
done so much um
change the culture in basketball in the
nba
look at all those blessings that god did
for me look at all those things that he
did for me just getting drafted would
have been enough
you know what i mean just being on a
team would have been enough but all
those acting ladies all those things
that i was blessed with all those
accomplishments
i didn't want a championship
um
he didn't want that for me
you know obviously he wanted all those
other things for me and um
he made me so proud of um
first of all myself but
my mom my dad the people that raised me
um
all of the people that helped me because
you don't do it by yourself all of those
people that that helped me all of the
little league coaches that i had um all
of the teammates that i had from
you know from little league all the way
up to you know college you know
teammates the guys that set the screens
for me um passed me the ball the
trainers
you know what i mean the medical people
everybody you know what i mean that's
why when i when i became a hall of famer
and i went up there
and i talked about
you know the ups and downs that i went
through
in my life and as a as an athlete
um a lot of people stuck with me a lot
of people
you know went away but a lot of people
stuck with me and that's what it meant
why it meant so much for me when i went
up there and said now you know y'all are
hall of famers too yeah i am you know
what i mean so
it it it bothered me that i didn't win
one and um they try to separate
um the great players from the other
great players because some of them
didn't win championships but i won in a
lot of ways absolutely do you do you all
think
we maybe have too much of an emphasis on
ring culture
i i don't think so because that's the
ultimate goal it's a team game you know
what i mean um and and that separates
the best from the best it does you know
what i mean um
and that's a that's that's something
tough because i i got there
but i ran against you know a juggernaut
with shaquille o'neal and kobe bryant
you know what i mean they were so great
that they made everybody around them
you know so much better um and you know
we were a great team but we just got
beat by a better team mm-hmm yeah
absolutely i think you know i i had
chris paul on my show last year maybe
the year before that we were talking
about championships and he's like you
know what i want to be a champion in
life like you know it means more to me
to be a you know a great husband a great
dad he's like i obviously want that but
there are so many other things that i'm
also fighting for as well and and that's
my little man and i understand him
wholeheartedly you know what i mean but
playing that game the ultimate goal it's
the winner it's doing it all yeah i mean
we all want to be champions off the
court we always we want to be
the best i i can't stand when people say
you know i don't care about what nobody
thinks about me whatever what i do
you know what i mean
i do you're not just going to call me
anything or say anything about me that's
not true and think it's not gonna
resonate with me you think it's not
gonna bother me um
but
we all wanna be champions in life we
always wanna be the people like i always
say you know i can make a mistake i just
don't want to make it twice
you know what i mean so we always want
to be
not the perfect person because
you know
there's no life being a perfect person
because you can't learn from nothing you
can't be strong you can't you know
overcome you can't you can't do any of
those things and and test who you are as
a person if you have a perfect life yeah
but you know we all wouldn't be
champions off the court but our damn
show wanted to be one on the court yeah
uh i know but you know that's everyone
says it's like that that man deserved a
ring you really really fought for it
that's that's that's the only thing that
makes me feel good at the end of the day
i can look at myself in the mirror and
know that i played every game like it
was my last
well that was one thing on the phone
james was saying that i think resonates
with him so much with you and why he
feels like there's kind of this
relatability with you is he feels that
he's misunderstood
um he feels like he is maybe judged in
some ways and his next question was how
do you think your career would have been
different if it was like this social
media era you know where everyone has an
opinion can talk about you oh man way
more out of control out of control yeah
out of control and i'm so glad
i'm so glad you know what i mean yeah my
instagram instead of 10 million it would
have been
50 60 100 million you know you never
know but
i wouldn't i wouldn't i wouldn't want to
trade the way it is right now you know
what i mean it would have been too out
of control
um
back then
and god know what he's doing so i trust
i trust that that part right there i
know he know what he's doing how should
current nba players deal with being
judged by others
you concentrate on the people
that love you if in the nba is going to
be what
my outlook was it's going to be
millions of people that love you it's
gonna be million people that hate you
concentrate on the ones that like
you know what i mean that's a lot of
people to concentrate on if if you know
you concentrate on millions of people
then you ain't got no time to be
concentrating on the ones that hate you
so you concentrate on the ones that love
you and and know who you are believe in
who you are and
love who you are you know what i mean um
i love who i am as a man who has as a
person as the the person that i involved
into the family man the the friend the
business partner you know what i mean um
love being yourself what's wrong with
being you everybody else in the world is
taking up there's only one right yeah
yeah
yeah well you know one thing i love
about both of you
is like
y'all are haters right a lot of like the
older generation
of nba players they want to be like we
were the best this new generation we not
you know and i think that
it probably is you know difficult to see
the changing of the guard of some things
you know seeing the new wave and
understanding okay well mine is maybe a
little bit of the past do you agree that
it's kind of hard for people to to let
go of that of that time yeah i think it
i think it is for some right yeah i
think for me i know it was different for
him because he came in as a number one
pick or whatever but like i kind of
experienced that with some of the older
players i played with right and i just
kind of made it a thing like i'll never
be like that i won't be old and bitter
and you know what i'm saying yeah i'm
gonna take care of my business and when
the game is done with me it's done with
me and that's fine you know what i'm
saying you have to just look at it like
how i look at it is we've just continued
to push the ball forward to now what you
see now and all the success and the
contracts and different things like that
right i want that for our five little
brothers you know i mean like this is a
fraternity and how i look at every
player that is in the league that's my
little brother right any of them can get
my ear any time because of what we've
done was so rare you know it was only
450 of us and we came in i think like
400 during that time yeah there's 30
million people that have nba aspirations
there's only 450 of us now you know so
for me it's always been about that that
camaraderie and just you know looking at
the players behind me is just being
little bros and that's why i think for
me you know i'm never that hater as you
say yeah and you're a fan and you're
you're you're a fan like
i was a fan when i was playing right you
know what i mean i'm a i'm a
i'm a fan of those guys like i get my
popcorn and you know my um
nba tv and i watch it and
you know what i mean i
you know watch all my favorite players
and
you know what i mean like and then at
the end of the day
you didn't want nobody to treat you like
that yeah you didn't want nobody hating
on you mm-hmm you know what i mean so so
why would you do it and then that go
back to what i was saying when you look
in that mirror it don't lie right the
truth gonna come out you look right in
that mirror right yeah and anything
going to stop nothing right being upset
and being bitter ain't gonna stop yeah
don't stop nothing you look in that
mirror and you're gonna see the word
hater written right on your forehead
you gotta walk around and live that you
gotta you gotta live that fake life yeah
you know what i mean what he said about
them being all little brothers i love
that i love being 46 years old and and
they come up to me and say big bro and
they say um you know what i mean because
honestly
i look back at the guy that made me want
to play the game michael jordan like how
could i ever hate on the man that gave
me the vision yeah that made allen
iverson want to play basketball and how
could i ever say
or hate on him yeah like the guy and i
would it would break my heart if he was
to
hate on me and i think the same way
about how the younger dudes feel they
grew up off of me
so you know me hating on them that
probably would crush them man yeah i
wouldn't i wouldn't do it anyway but i'm
just
thinking about it
that's terrible
tell me something that a younger player
has come up and said the way that you
have either impacted their game or their
life like you've never really said
before that really sticks with you that
you remember if it wasn't for you i
wouldn't be here
so many of them say that and how much i
inspired them
and and how much
you know my size
you know they thought about not being
big enough tall enough strong enough you
know what i mean and you know
how
i impacted their life
and and and made their dream come true
you know just by believing
um in themselves like i believed in
myself
you know what i mean and just the why
not factor why not me
you know what i mean why not yeah and
you only live once i mean that's what i
i think i don't know anybody that died
and came back
and if i did and if i did when i if i
died and came right back i would rather
be me all over again just probably a
polished version a little bit better
that's all yeah
a way more polished version
okay so we know obviously the game has
evolved in a bunch of ways i want you
guys to tell me
a way that you love the game has evolved
and the way that you kind of wish stayed
the same
what i like i just like the uh skill
level of the game yeah because i watch
like
you know i watch a player do a
in between like between as they say
tween
and then end up over there
like it's just amazing like how did you
like what made you possess you to try
that and it's not a travel you know so i
just really just like how the game has
evolved and i also
and it's funny because i try to figure
out sometime like how cause like you see
now girls are dunking more mm-hmm right
like i'm saying in high school level you
know i watch a lot of little highlights
though over time and all these different
whatever things and you see girls
dunking i'm like how are they and i'm
thinking it's like it's seeing us
believing like he said like how a lot of
kids saw him so he did and it gave them
the confidence that they ended up being
in the show yeah so i just think that
just i i just really enjoy how the game
is just truly really evolving and just
not and really just sitting back kind of
thinking like where's it going to go
because i got little boys that are six
and four and i want them to play and i'm
thinking like what do i start working on
them with now
there's so much
versatility in the game now so uh you
know that's something that just really
impresses me about you know this this
day and time yeah i think i i always
wonder this
if you were playing with the way that
basketball is now do you think he'd be a
better player same player less player
i would i mean just betting on myself i
would say better better player because
it's more wide open you know what i mean
um
the game is
it's a lot more wide open um the quarter
spread big time because you got big men
that can um they can shoot now yeah i
mean that's why you know the game has
changed um like what i was saying you
got guys 6 9 16 he basically kind of
started that you know would have been a
big man that could handle the ball like
that on the perimeter but you got katie
seven feet you handle the ball like a
point guard yeah like how do you guard
yeah
i mean like steph curry is incredi
he's
not human he's different you know what i
mean like that's what i love that that
part of the evolution of the game just
seeing
it change so much you know people talk
about my handle and stuff like that like
i was not handling the ball like steph
and kyrie and guys like that like they
are doing out of this world things with
the ball
you know what i mean
but
you know
in this new wave i would i would just
think that
i would have gotten better and
you know
did some some of the things or even more
than i was doing then yeah you know what
i mean like now
when i was playing you know
when i was in college when i came out my
teammates used to always say well damn
you know chuck
when you get to the league
they can't um run a boxing one on you
they can't run any zones on you and it's
down at third and i was like damn that's
right they gotta play me one-on-one all
game i'm gonna have a sporty every night
yeah and then you know
four scoring titles and then all of a
sudden now they got zones now
all these gimmick defenses
now they you know double teaming and
every time somebody touched the ball so
you know i might i might have had
something to do with right them going
back to the zone because you remember
how in the nba it was never you can
never play zone so you start killing one
on one then you got this dude six feet
165 pounds with the scoring titles alone
now
you know we're gonna change the rule all
the way right now you can run a zone
you know i played in the east so we play
against you in the playoffs i felt like
my first three years and they used to
get so bad in the film session but like
you know what just let him score we just
stop everybody else
but it's so crazy to think about things
that are kind of like the ai rule you
know what i mean like that really could
be one we also know the dress code like
that all those things like the impact
that you had the things that changed
because of your presence is just
i think really cool and just speaks so
much to the legacy you see how but you
see how dope it is i mean
maybe rest in peace you know with him
changing it with him changing the dress
code
it was like
i mean it was like you taking the
identity of these people awake because
nobody play the same we don't play the
same
we don't look the same
you know what i mean so why should we
dress the same
you know what i mean my mentality all
was always when when i was coming in my
rookie year i was like
basically
now i can buy
all the clothes
that the guys from around my way want
and wear anything that i want to wear
cause i can afford it now so i'm a dress
like this when i was leaving from the
arena i was going to the club i won't go
into church or
you know what i mean like when when you
know coming up when i'm from when you
wore a suit you was wearing a suit to
church or a funeral or something like
that you know what i mean and
my whole thing was when everybody saw me
dressing the way i was dressing like i
wanted to like
and everybody started doing it the nba
was like hold on
you know what i mean and it gave us
and i know what it was it was like kind
of a
thug look yeah you know what i mean
when everybody was wearing suits when i
came up i never wore no suit to the park
to go play basketball i wore a sweatsuit
or whatever and the clothes don't make
the person no yeah no no what people
when people go uh rob a bank and all
that what they have on suits
okay you know what i mean and
now it's beautiful you might not like
what these guys are wearing but it's
beautiful you know what i mean because
they wearing and expressing themselves
the way they're not wearing the skirts
though
i'm not even gonna go there
i love the fashion i love it
you own your own look i'm into it i love
playing with fashion i'm not going there
but i love it it's beautiful because i
like to see everybody with their own
they got their own swag and their own
personalities and
you know what i mean
yeah i love it but you know you look
back on and it's like you really think
about like the psychology of why
what you look like scared so many people
and how bad that is how bad that we
thought we had to change people because
we felt so unsure about one person
because they never seen it people were
always scared of something they never
seen
you know what i mean unless it's
beneficial to them yeah you know what i
mean unless it makes them feel good but
if it makes you uncomfortable in any way
you won't have a problem with it
especially when you're a high power you
know what i mean we use the generations
of everybody looking like this
everybody's supposed to look like
michael jordan you know what i mean i
wanted to look like him on the court i
wanted to look like a superhero like i
don't understand why guys right now wear
different colored shoes in their uniform
but that's the new era i always looked
at it like what superman wore red
white it was red yellow and blue right
batman wore you know
uh yellow and black and spider-man wore
blue black and red you know what i mean
they all matched all the way down yeah
and that's the way i played when mike
played he matched his shoes matches
uniform and all that mm-hmm so
you know but it was weird too with the
whole thug thing right because when you
think about it like what we were wearing
right like we went 1500 shoes right 500
they never but they never they never
seen they never seen a dude ragging a
hat like they never they they never seen
it and it got scary you know what i mean
i remember being put on the cover of
magazines when i was the face of the nba
but they would airbrush my tattoos off
like i remember those things happening
which is wild
like they're taking parts of you yeah we
want some of you we want your game and
we want some of you we don't want the
cornrows now we want the tattoos
but everything else you know
we we cool with and everybody's making a
big deal about my cornrows like i was
just
you we can curse over here yeah i was
tired of people [ __ ] my hair up on
the road yeah you know what i mean like
they i was getting haircuts they were
destroying i was like okay if i just
grow my hair out and get cornrows then i
don't have to worry about that yeah and
that was the only reason i did it and he
had nothing to do with me trying to look
like a thug
or be a thug and then you know what i
mean i was just tired of people messing
my head up yeah
i had them problems
hey you know one thing we grew out of
that i'm like ooh it's good we got no
more 10 slides is too big for a.m
party is over yeah
my teammates used to get mad as hell at
me like i used to go in big and tall and
buy everything up wait wait you really
went into big and tired i was about
being 4x t-shirts
forty-five that's wild and they used to
go in there they just come in here i'm
talking about a big man on the team yeah
and they said at the practice i would
beat them there
you know what i mean and i would buy
everything and they'd come in here and
get mad at me because i would buy up all
the big clothes did you just like the
look like did you want to look like
you've been kind of swallowed by by your
clothes it was in style
and then i was you know i had to
probably i had the little man complex
because i always wanted the big old
rolls royce and the biggest car and you
know what i mean i was
165 then so yeah you know i wanted the
biggest clothes i didn't want to look
small
smaller than everybody else so
i don't know and it was a style back
then i don't know who i
don't know it was just the guys from my
neighborhood used to dress like that so
i used to dress like that some iconic
looks though it's like it's fine it's
okay yeah but when you look at it now
like your head look like beetlejuice
like
the smallest head
and your body just your clothes is big
look crazy
look crazy okay so as you all can see he
gives some really good quotes
uh but one of my favorite quotes of
yours you said i'm not a point guard i'm
a killer
i want you to tell me five guys playing
right now you're like they're killers
steph curry
kevin durant
james harden
um
james harden oh what's the smile for
because i know a lot of killers yeah um
bradley bill
is the killer
oh
damn dang
dang dame's the killer certified yeah
certified oh why are you getting so
excited about dane what about dame cause
dame just
he's a monster with it like he's he's um
he's kind of
stuff is just
just bad as hell
but
damn just so rude [ __ ]
like he just rude he's just
disrespectful he just do anything just
i mean
pass half court and just let it fly
buzzer beat us he
at the hash you know what i mean just
like
no fear no i mean just nothing he's a
he's not just a killer he's a serial
killer
that's so good
this is what he shout out to yeah big
shout out
you know speaking of dame i also asked
dave if he had a question for you and i
have one from him as well um which
actually makes me think of another one
of your quotes which was when someone
asked you about coaching you said i'm
coaching because i don't want to coach
no [ __ ] make more money than me
does that say does that stand yeah
because i mean i'm just saying it's like
it's like i always got i have the utmost
respect for coaches in the nba yeah and
just i mean coaches worldwide but in the
nba it's totally different like you you
have all of these guys making all this
money everybody on the team make more
money than you
and you're able honestly you're able to
bring these guys together
and get them to believe in one thing
yeah and that's playing the right way
and winning and having them
all with the same mindset and the same
goal
in their head and they buy into it you
know what i mean to ultimately win a
championship you know what i mean
that's power yeah and that's respect you
know what i mean when you got these guys
you know they make all this money
and they buying in everything that you
know
that you say and and this is a lot of
guys you got guys on different teams
with max contracts that they probably
feel like you know they supposed to be
the man yeah but somehow they somehow
some way
to make it all work they fit in a role
play their role and then
all the success comes and that one guy
that's leaving you know what i mean
supposed to get his flowers okay well
then i wonder if you i'll read james
question to you and if this is something
that
you would be interested in his question
was let me get it right
have you thought about
just training current players like not
full time but just working i would love
that and i would love i would love um
i'm glad you asked me that
and shout out to dan
definitely shout out to name and and
i don't want it i want to say nothing
too bad um
you know who i'm talking to but i'd
rather help
i've i've i know
i've forgotten more basketball than some
people know
and i know i can help an organization
get better
um
i know so much of the ins and outs in
basketball and not just
um talent wise as far as you know who's
good who's not anybody know kevin durant
is good you know what i mean but i know
other things when it comes to basketball
i know the look
i know i know the eyes i know i know the
um the posture
um
i know things inside of basketball
that other people might not might not
know that i experienced um throughout my
career and throughout my life you know
what i mean i can
get on a basketball court and tell if
somebody's scared of me by just looking
at them you know what i mean i can look
at your demeanor and see that you don't
want it tonight maybe tomorrow night or
the night before but not tonight
and i just i just know so many things
ins and out in basketball relationships
how teammates react to each other
what they have a problem with what makes
them play a certain way
are they a certain way through this
quarter the next one the next one or the
next one how they are in overtime
if the ball feel like a hot potato in
their hand yeah what i mean do they want
it
you know what i mean i know those things
about players and i know what an
organization i know i can help you know
not
the the guy that's you know right up
front and everything but just behind the
scenes i know i can help a lot of
athletes well okay so when i asked you
the question you were smiling
you smiled and you said okay hold on i'm
trying to hesitate because everybody
know who i would rather help
everybody know that okay you don't care
to be specific everybody i'm a sixer for
life okay i'm i'm all i got six of blood
coming through me so everybody know that
i want to help their organization
i've been retired what
11 years
don't know how i'm not a part of that
staff some kind of way yeah almost like
a consultant that would be really nice
even it was that i would be
i would be the happiest in the world
yeah and the money thing ain't got
nothing to do with it
it's just just me being me and me being
a sixer and one to help i don't know why
nothing's been put in place for me and i
still love y'all don't get it choices
it's all love it ain't gonna never go
nowhere but i just there's something
that i just don't understand yeah i mean
i totally see that in the future even
when i was like asking guys if they had
questions you everyone just gets so
excited they want to soak up the
knowledge that you have and i know they
might not think i might not they might
think i might not show up to work or
might
come in my office and i mean when i do
rags
they might think i won't dress right and
then and i mean i know i can't come in
there dressing like this and that's what
it means
hey that's the problem i mean it might
be that but if it is that then address
it right mm-hmm dress it i don't have no
problem with having no contract with
stipulations in my country it's just
like i'm signing um nba contract i mean
you know if you're a player
you know i don't i don't have no problem
with no clauses in my stuff and yeah you
know what i mean it is what it is and
that's up to me to accept it or not yeah
and i mean that what they would gain
from having you it's so monumental
obviously um
somebody around there don't think like
you think yeah
we gonna get you get you a job my
manager will be pissed off with me after
this problem
hey you're just being you it's all good
i do want to pick both of y'all's brain
with basketball though because i loved
hearing different things you were saying
you can see you know if someone's scared
right you know if they're ready you can
just tell by looking at them
right now it's kind of a watershed
moment in the nba where we're seeing the
younger guys become stars it's new
generations coming up so i want to name
a young player let's do like kind of the
under 25 players y'all tell me what you
like about their game
and what they can improve in their game
all right
we'll start with jayson tatum
what i like about what i like about his
game is you know he does everything
really well
right
i just
think
i'm just looking more from a leadership
standpoint from him like that's i think
that's his next step in my opinion okay
just really where
he controls that organization and take
that next step because you hear a lot of
comparisons of like you know kobe and
different things like that so those are
huge shoes to fill like
yeah right huge so i just think for me
for what i see from him is just that
that ownership of his locker room and
that's what i would like to see from him
i think he'll take it to the next level
yeah
yeah i respect what um
what i was saying because i'm looking at
it
from that perspective obviously you've
been paying attention to that and i mean
it's al harrington so obviously you
gotta take it for what it is as far as
his
everything else
got it
got it nothing wrong
i mean i don't see nothing wrong he in
that killer category yeah definitely i
don't see i don't there's nothing that
he can't do on the basketball court so
if there's anything um
that he might need to improve on
obviously it got to be something like in
the locker room or something yeah yeah
his talent is unreal it's like he makes
everything look so easy
like yeah it's quite controlled
never looked rattled yeah never in like
i mean since rookie year just poised all
the time uh trae young
i also am a hawks fan you should know so
[Music]
again
um
i don't and i know he and he's a leader
um and they listen to him as young as he
is
i don't see no flaws
you know what i mean all i all i know is
he's just gonna get better and better so
all i would say is just keep doing what
you doing i don't see no flaws in this
game at all yeah and you guys can just
tell me what you like about their game
if you don't on the fly i like
everything about this game okay yeah he
like he's steph curry 2.0 right
yeah just shorter shorter and got a
little bit more a little swag to him
yeah a little bit more swag yeah
who gotta love me most way
i think ice tray dude steph got a lot of
swag
i know this was like
he was in new york though yeah see
and you know new york they gonna give it
to you new york philadelphia they gonna
give it to you so he had no choice but
to interact with them but i don't think
steph i don't think steph would have did
that no
too cool yeah well the difference is
it's like how everyone was saying trey
accepted that villain role you know he
would go into these arenas that are away
and he would be the villain steph has a
lot of swag but he's not going in as the
bad guy he's just going as the guy who's
going to shoot the lights out and [ __ ]
he's going to just kill you get out of
here yeah
what about john morant another young guy
only only thing that
that might he might
be anything less than um
a
ah and i would say that probably a a a
minus o
or b plus
it's probably the only thing you
probably could say is his jumper
that's the only thing you probably could
that's the only
and and he he can make that mm-hmm so
i'm just saying just go moving forward
once his jumper is basically automatic
trouble trouble could he trouble right
now
he's
trouble right now all the point guards
right now yeah all the points right now
oh and then that go back to it and he's
a killer in a different way because he
can do it in a point guard style you
know what i mean he can do it all kinds
of ways you know what i mean what this
is you know what i mean scoring
he got the whole package he can do it
all you just name it all the bad boys
all right
all the young bad [ __ ] but that
is so exciting to think about just this
new generation everyone is so good in
good hands the nba and adam silva
and more so
standing ovation for the fans yes yes
for the fans you know what i mean i mean
they got the the product is there on the
floor they're good for years to come
but the fans are so great in arenas
across the world you know what i mean
they're they're they're supporting them
teams the games are great the fans are
back in the stands and for all of us
fans i mean
we're back yeah i love it okay one more
young guy luca
he about him my top five wait wait top
five in the league period right now
yeah
okay then that you gotta name your whole
top five
and do you agree with that
luca is crazy
yeah you were but you said there was a
bunch of killers so we know yeah
certified yeah yeah you're just saying
some of your favorites
what i like about him so much is that
he
he just played the game he played the
game he's fearless
yeah like it's just that
to this point hot potato all that ain't
none of that in him
and especially and especially coming
from where he came from right because
normally you think that like you know
those guys take some time to adjust but
he's been talking [ __ ] the whole time
he's really busting ass
every single night yeah he wants so it
don't matter it don't matter you can put
your best defender on him he top five
bro like yeah
it's funny and i don't want to go
through my top five like that but like
nah al if you say someone's top five you
have to say you're tough like because
you got we got to know who's in who's
that you need the context
so you got katie okay one you got
giannis okay
oh man
oh man
god
i'm still going lbj i know you're the og
yeah no you don't know i ain't putting
him in no caps
okay so that makes it even easier then
so that means i can slide anthony davis
back in there
yeah for my top five um
steph curry
right
and and luke no james no james
i mean no james i mean
man averaging michael jordan numbers 36
and
i mean scoring title at the scoring
title we're talking about killers now
we're talking about
straight kills james is in it because i
mean because because i throw james and
and then sometimes i have kawhi
right kawhi throws me off because he
just don't play enough games
yeah i mean for a top five i mean and i
i love lucas game but i mean that's
really high praise luca already right
now in the top five he got it and then
and james this is the first time james
hasn't um you know has been hurt like
this like throughout his career he won't
he was never
you know i mean he was always available
yeah um but yeah luca i mean he's a
killer he got a
he probably got a cult man
i ain't lying that man is a killer man
yeah do you are you in pretty good
agreement with his top five
okay so that name james right
named her name
so your killers are your top five all
right i like that yeah i might keep my
my killers uh yeah so you gotta put
james in there james and then obviously
james yeah yeah i mean um so would you
go james with anthony
davis as far as killers yeah
i'm going with i'm going with um james
are you crazy
how many scoring titles uh i ain't got
it no you got none of them that's what
i'm saying we're talking about putting
the ball in the basket
that's what we were saying
couple more before i let you go i'm
curious for you who right now
kind of feels like the most ai like
who's the new generation allen iverson
to you i obviously no one is duplicated
but who's closest to kind of what you
brought to the game
on the court
damn
do i want to say
job yeah i like john for you like
y'all
i don't know because it's my job for you
because like to me job represents like
hip-hop and all like i don't know for me
every time i see him i see little baby
right right like him like that like
and that's kind of what you represent
with his homeboys and all that
in the way and john just cool he just
moved he's just cool
cool it wasn't extra it was just you and
crew thick yeah you know what i'm saying
so he that's who and then i would say
like i like to i like to when when i um
when i compare like
i can't never compare nobody to me like
that because they're never
my size like everybody always like
they'll have a category and they'd be
like the best little man or the best
little man dunker and i seen it you know
on tv the other day and i wasn't up
there and they had the best little man
dunkers but they had guys up there six
five
six six you know what i mean six three
steph curry is not a little man right at
six three right you know what i mean
like
and then when you try to compare
somebody with me there's never nobody my
size to whereas i can say okay
he get buckets
and he'll bang it too yeah you know what
i mean like and that's what i'd be you
know or in here clown you too you know
what i mean and i'm and i just
when i think of somebody it's always got
to be somebody that's three or four
inches
taller than me so it's hard to you know
put me in a category like
you know
if you think about it
what person six feet in a league yeah
that's gonna give it to you yeah you
know what i'm saying it ain't only the
only person i could think of that was
on that level
in a vicious state was isaiah
isaiah coming when that last year at
boston before he got hurt
and the year before that isaiah coming
28 29 a game
you know what i mean and then
the injury and then i look at isaiah's
situation he was never put in
a good situation again to whereas he
could just be isaiah and then everybody
else follow him right you know what i
mean and you know because he went
uh
cleveland and he was who was there
claiming that lebron was yeah then he
went to l.a lebron is there you know
what i mean then he went to the
new orleans and then they got three
stars already you know what i mean so he
was never it was never in his game he
was just never put in a situation or uh
yeah just a situation to where
he could succeed you know what i mean
and
shout out to isaiah
um still rooting for you i love you yeah
you know what i mean and you know if
anybody can get through this you can
yeah and just stay up stay strong and
believe in yourself believe in god okay
well you know they're wanting me to wrap
up i do have
one more for you guys i also need to say
like i have enjoyed this so much just
soaking up all this basketball from you
guys and just hearing you talk about
life and everything you've learned has
been a pleasure pleasure gotta think
about the person that's asking the
questions
it can know it it can only be
great you know it can be real boring if
you actually if you're not asking the
right stuff but it can be great if you
asking the right things and not just and
not the same things that everybody else
had oh thank you so much i've been doing
this for 25 26 years and i get the same
questions and the same stuff all the
time so it's good that those who you
know make make a pot of gumbo and add
some different stuff up in there oh wait
hey that is like
such high phrase i i appreciate that
thank you so much appreciate it yeah we
got a pot of gumbo but i do have one
more for you guys just i think it's been
really cool to see
the different stages of life you've seen
like on the court and off the court you
have gone through so much it has played
out in front of so many people
you have yeah you have obviously you're
not this businessman you've learned so
much i just want to know through life
what you credit kind of just your
resiliency to
and what has allowed you to you know
stay you throughout all of this
both of you
i mean i'm probably quick um
it was all my upbringing you know my uh
really close-knit family my mom was the
superhero in my family
uh
i
my dad died young when i was young he
was young i was young obviously eight
years old and the relationship that me
and my mother kind of the bond we built
from there
is who i am today you know and it's just
i'm the same person like you know most
people not everybody that knows me from
when i was eight years old to 41 years
old they'll tell you i'm the same person
yeah and i just really think it's just
really just from the foundation that my
mom laid you know which was just around
integrity yeah you know what i'm saying
doing the right thing and what's right
is right and what's wrong is wrong and
that's just kind of how i live my life
and i think that you know that's why i
am who i am today
i love that what about you
my family
um
my family
being there for me
me caring so much about them and wanting
to
be able to
create
a better life for them
um
and the second part was
what how you've been able to stay you
throughout everything even
and that's been that's been the easiest
part for me
um is being the same person
that the people that love me and the
people that i love are able to recognize
all the time no matter what the ups and
downs
um how much money how much fame
you know what i mean just um
just
wanting to be that as well you know what
i mean and feeling like there's nothing
wrong with it so it was never a point
where i felt like selling out and and
becoming something um that i'm not and
selling out
doesn't mean
um not doing all the right things that
you're supposed to do or getting in
trouble or you know being being mean to
somebody and you know
being nice is cool too you know what i
mean i love when um a [ __ ] meet
me and they say you're nothing like
i thought you would be or you're nothing
like i heard you or what they said you
know what i mean because you never met
me you know what i mean you can't judge
me if if you never met me you get
somebody else can have a different
opinion of me because of the
circumstances of when i met them you
know i mean you might have wanted to uh
have a conversation with me or have me
sign something or take a picture while
i'm feeding my daughter and i tell you
that this is not the right time can you
wait down finish this and
the person well [ __ ] you man
[ __ ] you ain't better than kobe
bryant anyway and i like kobe anyway and
matter of fact i don't watch basketball
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
so
so and then you asked them about allen
iverson yeah a week later and they said
well he's an [ __ ] you know
this guy asked him to take a picture or
whatever and he wouldn't do it but they
ain't gonna leave the part out that he
was feeding his daughter or whatever to
tell half the story yeah so
well i i'm really happy that we
hopefully we're able to give the full
story i think that's important so thank
you guys so much i know we we got a
bunch of this so we should probably end
this
oh yeah we should probably in the
interview i feel like we gotta test it
out
[Laughter]
no but thank you all so much for your
time this is amazing yeah this is great